la question est la suivante pourquoi est
ce que nos smartphones coûte si cher si
vous vous intéressez au marché des
smartphones vous constaterez que les
tigers ont tendance à augmenter plutôt
qu'à diminuer de plus en plus de marques
frôle les 1000 euros en tout cas se
rapproche et pas mal de marques ont
passé le palier des 1000 euros pour
atteindre 1300 avoir plus de 1600 euros
je donc répondre à cette question
pourquoi est ce que nos smartphones
coûte si cher
je vais tout vous expliquer tout vous
détailler on va se faire débaucher map
c'est une question qui est extrêmement
intéressante et qui souhaitent pas mal
de réflexion pour répondre à cette
question
on a besoin d'un marqueur post-it de
feuilles et on a besoin de monde mais
note le schéma de base extrêmement
simple vous avez une marque qui vend un
produit à un client ça c'est la base du
commerce
maintenant il ya plusieurs notions à
comprendre la première c'est la question
du coût de fabrication qu'est ce que
coûte à produire un smartphone
on a des données qui nous viennent de
techinsights qui ont estimé composant
par composant plus la production locale
ce que coûtait à produire un iphone 11
promax ans à son douzième de stockage
je vous affiche le détail sur l'écran
pour la faire très très simple on voit
que la partie photo coûte 73,50 dollars
l'écran 66,50 dollars
la batterie 10,50 dollars et on a un
total de 481 10,50 dollars
on va faire un petit retour dans le
passé avec le tarif d'un iphone 7 plus
qui coûtait à produire 270 7,66 dollars
l'iphone 8 plus coûté 280 15,44 dollars
l'iphone 10 et c'est un des smartphones
le plus intéressant qui vous expliquerai
pourquoi un peu plus tard coûté à
produire 370 dollars on a ensuite
l'iphone 10 s max qui lui coûtait à
produire 4 143 $ et on arrive sur notre
iphone 11 pro mac ce qui lui coûte comme
on vient de le voir 480 10,50 dollars
bon là je vous parle d'apple mais y'a
pas qu'apple n'avait aussi samsung avec
son galaxy s 8 qui coûtait à produire
300 7,50 dollars
et récemment le galaxy s 20 ultras qui
coûtait à produire 500 28,52
ce qui est extrêmement intéressant c'est
qu'un iphone on se promet axe coûte
quatre fois 90 dollars à produire et se
vendent à la version 512 giga 1449
dollars de la même manière un samsung
s20 ultras se vend 1399 dollars si on
doit venir schématiser ici on voit que
coûte indications de smartphones
représentent environ 34 à 37 % du prix
de vente
ce qui veut donc dire qu'on à 65%
d'autres choses et qui compte énormément
dans l'addition
donc la question à se poser c'est à quoi
correspondent ces 65 % puisque ses 65
ans en voulait payer et je vous le dis
tout de suite ça ne correspond
absolument pas à ce que gagne la marque
elle ne gagne pas 65 % du prix banque
elle ne se met pas dans les poches
il ya beaucoup de choses qui rentrent en
compte et ça peut paraître des formes
très peu complexe on sait donc que notre
produit représente à peu près 35 % du
prix total mais notre marque
elle a quand même pas mal du coup elle a
différents coûts liés en r&d elle a bien
évidemment des coûts qui sont liées au
design la conception les différentes
fonctionnalités
les prototypes vous payer tout le
travail des os que ce soit une licence
android ou alors tout développement au
niveau des os les marques elles aussi
beaucoup de charges en terme d'emplois
que ce soit des emplois administratifs
que ce soit les contacts que ce soit
pour l'entretien de ses locaux et là
aussi tous ces investissements qui sont
répercutés que vous payez également vous
paye également tout le sav ado bien
évidemment payé tous ses actionnaires et
elle doit donc tirer une marge pour
gagner de l'argent
donc tout ça c'est des choses qui vont
être compris dans le prix de votre
produit et que vous allez payer sans
forcément vous en rendre compte
ensuite il ya autre chose qui intervient
ici entre le produit et les clients
c'est toute la question de la
distribution puisque forcément le
produit il va pas tes rires chez vous
comme ça là vont se rajouter différents
coûts notamment le coût de stockage les
coûts de logistique pour acheminer le
produisent des places on le prend on
emballe on le fait partir tous les coûts
de distribution puisque une entreprise
de s'occuper de la distribution et de
l'implanter dans différents magasins et
vous avez bien évidemment tous les
magasins qui sont là aussi pour gagner
de l'argent
donc ça aussi c'est pour vous
complètement invisible mais ça vous
allez également le payer mais il ya
autre chose que vous allez payer c'est
la communication entre la marque et vous
et ça on l'appelle le marketing c'est
donc les différentes actions qui vont
être mis en place pour venir vous vendre
un produit
la communication de la marque
directement d'un client final c'est un
vaste sujet est ce un tarif qui va
vraiment varié d'une marque à l'autre
alors en marketing vous avez bien
évident
tout ce qui va être publicité partant de
la création avec les différentes agences
si vous avez des prises de paroles de
célébrités eh bien ça se paye et ensuite
les spots coûte cher à diffuser ce soit
en télé en radio sur le web en affichage
et même dans vos points de vente dans
les différents magasins avec de l'appel
autant vous dire que la partie marketing
j'ai souvent quelque chose qui coûte
très très cher et qui aussi une part
importante dans l'équation donc
aujourd'hui strictement incapable de
vous donner les clés de répartition mais
maintenant vous dire ce que coûte le
marketing par rapport à la marge ça
fluctue d'une marque à l'autre
il vous en douterez les marques ne
communique pas dessus donc on a
absolument aucun chiffre officiel
maintenant je comprends mieux de quoi
est composé le prix d'un smartphone on
peut se demander pourquoi est ce que
l'état y ait des smartphones ont
toujours tendance à augmenter
il ya ce que j'appellerais un effet
accordéon il ya une vraie différence en
fonction des catégories de produits avec
un agrandissement des gammes
on avait avant l'entrée de gamme le
milieu de gamme et le haut de gamme
aujourd'hui vous avez l'un très l'entrée
de gamme l'entrée de gamme l'entrée
milieu de gamme le milieu de gamme le
milieu haut de gamme le haut de gamme et
l'ultra haut de gamme
on a donc un effet accordéon avec des
gammes qui tendent à s'allonger à se
complexifier
mais ce qui est vraiment intéressant à
voir c'est un étalement des tarifs tout
en gardant quand même des produits qui
sont intéressants qui vous permettront
de faire beaucoup de choses
beaucoup d'usagers que ce soit de la
photo des jeux pour les réseaux sociaux
pour le visionnage de série il y en a
pour toutes les bourses mais dans tout
ça il ya un point qui a été vraiment
révélateur il ya pas si longtemps que ça
et c'est ce que j'appellerais l'effet
iphone 10 quand on a commencé à parler
de l'iphone disent les premières rumeurs
parlaient d'un smartphone qui allait
coûter à peu près 1000 $ on doutait qu
en france le produit à l'écouté plus de
1000 euros et ce qu'a été le cas donc
quand apple a présenté son iphone 10 en
même temps que l'iphone 8 les analystes
disent et ce smartphone ne se vendra pas
il ne pourra pas marcher il coûte
beaucoup trop cher et c'est ça qui est
extrêmement intéressant et c'est la
vision très juste d'apple en créant une
nouvelle catégorie de produits ce qu'on
appellera aujourd'hui l'ultra haut de
gamme donc ici vous avez les meilleures
technologies
mais pour les marques vous avez surtout
une forte valeur une image de marque qui
va être accrue vous avez surtout des
tarifs qui sont beaucoup plus élevés et
ça c'est la cerise sur le gâteau des
marges qui sont également plus élevés
donc des produits s'ils vendent bien qui
vous rapporte beaucoup d'argent
on a donc un effet iphone 10 qui a créé
un effet accordé au niveau des gares et
toutes les marques veulent y aller apple
bien évidemment la première puisque
c'est elle qui à l'origine de tout ça
samsung avec toujours plus de produits
dans la gamme ss20 s20 plus en
connaissez déjà mais avec l'avènement
cette année du s20 ultra 5 g ou est plus
à commencer le virage année dernière
avec un modèle professionnel et va
encore plus loin cette année avec son
one + 8 pro alors c'était une marque
était mono produit même si on a vu une
version évoluée dans la deuxième partie
de l'année maintenant 20 points de plus
non place une stratégie de gamme schumi
qui était connu pour être le fait la
chip qui leur cas et donc tuer les
smartphones les plus haut de gamme en
proposant les meilleures technologies au
tarif le plus bas
eh bien on voit que la marque a
également fait le choix d'élargir sa
gamme vers le très haut de gamme et on
l'a vu notamment avec un milices pro qui
flirte avec les 1000 euros ou envoyé
également avec son p 40 prend plus et
c'est presque l'effet inverse avec apple
on voit que la marque tend à s'élargir
d'un milieu de gamme en renouvelant son
iphone est ce le cas de schumi est
particulièrement intéressant puisque
c'est une marque qui dit ne pas faire
plus de 5% de marge
la marque dit à ses consommateurs on n'a
pas gagné beaucoup d'argent vous
proposer les meilleures technologies aux
tarifs les plus bas
mais là où c'est extrêmement intéressant
et très malin c'est qu'on parle de marge
moyenne sur l'année puisque smartphones
comme le 1010 pro aura des marges bien
plus élevées peut-être que sur l'année
ils resteront à des marges moyennes de
l'ordre de 5% voire un petit peu moins
mais sur des produits très haut de gamme
comme le milices pro là les marges sont
bien plus élevées et il ya également un
autre point à prendre en considération
en 2020 il ya une augmentation des
tarifs des smartphones sur le haut de
gamme sont ultra haut de gamme et qui va
continuer sur le milieu de gamme et
d'entrée de gamme c'est l'effet 5g
puisque oui les modèles 5g coûte plus
cher que les modèles 4g pour répondre à
la question pourquoi est ce que nos
smartphones font si cher et bien en fait
nos smartphones sont pas si cher il ya
un effet accordé au niveau des gammes si
vous voulez acheter un excellent
smartphone aux alentours 500 400 euros
et bien vous trouverez des choses
vraiment intéressantes plus vous allez
vous rapprocher du haut de gamme ultra
haut de gamme plus les smartphones
coûteront cher et vous vous en douterez
plus les smartphones sont chères plus
doit y avoir aussi un budget marketing
derrière et pourquoi est ce que les
marques vont mettre beaucoup d'argent
dans le marketing parce qu'elles veulent
que vous achetiez lors
duy plutôt que ceux des concurrents et
pourquoi est ce que les marques viennent
tout sur l'ultra haut de gamme
parce qu'il ya un beau et grand gâteau
et qu elles veulent toutes leurs parts
c'est pas une critique c'est un fait
c'est la loi du commerce c'est comme ça
a vous de me dire maintenant vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
quant à nous on se retrouve extrêmement
rapidement on continue à parler tech
nous envoient beaucoup d'amour a très
vite tels cas
[Musique]